when you saw Ray for Alston make it to
the league are you like it ain't over
for me he still made it yeah were a lot
of people like that
because he kind of kicked the door down
for the possibility to like
be as like a legendary Street baller so
his was different though so he actually
played all he went the regular I just
played three balls in the Summer Okay so
we're like full-time street ball like I
let go of school so his thing was he was
still going to school he was still doing
everything summer time it was he played
Community College right Fresno State got
drafted a little D-League then came back
up then signed a big deal a few big
deals but yeah uh
for The Other Guys
I mean anything's possible but I think a
lot of guys just didn't get that
opportunity or like there may be with
some shortcoming whether it was on the
court or off everybody's story is a
little bit different but dudes were good
enough to be that's the myth man they
did that documentary they did a doc on
and one last year on ESPN there's two
docs there's one on ESPN and one on
Netflix the one on ESPN had NBA players
kind of like bashing I don't even know
why this was in the dock if it's there
and one doc yeah but they were like
bashing the level of play of And1
players and uh it wasn't a good
narrative like it wasn't true why do the
documentary if you're gonna bash us I
didn't get it yeah I didn't understand
it I don't know but luckily most people
saw the Netflix stuff yeah um it's crazy
too because I think like
back then like there had to have been
like
for you guys like to hit the like what
was was y'all did y'all have like and
one groupies was there like chicks like
who's like [__] because you know what
the thing is that was a thing it was hip
hop it was a rock star hip hop
basketball tour yes it was you guys had
rappers on tour too right or was a
different city everybody did the
halftimes like like okay remember you're
just saying Cassidy was up here he was
doing but it was like Dip set the locks
uh I think when I saw it it was uh David
Banner and Roscoe David Banner killed it
bro oh my God Jackson Mississippi is
home it was wild listen I always say
this because I've I've always watched
guys do halftime shows and they'd be
like it's a little different people are
getting up to go to like get their
drinks but I'm like listen oh this is
lit I saw David Banner do a halftime
show and he was alone standing in the
middle of the court and he shut that
[__] the [__] down shut it down ain't
got up on the rim once he's like sat on
the rim it's crazy but uh no those half
times went off E40 actually killed it
like when we did the bay with the Bay
Area I'd play Oakland
I remember E-40 came on there and they
and uh what was it there was these other
dudes though
some local group it was like yeah they
hit the court and everybody ran the
court and they had to stop it because it
got it was like firework man yeah
exactly a high fear that was crazy but
every halftime for Antoine was like
super turned up what about uh what do
you think about Big Three
oh I think it's dope I love it I love it
I mean
I don't think like some people might
call that like street but I don't really
view it as like Streetball necessarily
but I think that like you're right guys
have more spin after the league you know
saying you might be good in the half
court until you're 50 like you're saying
so
so I think it's another uh it's another
Outlet to check out I feel like it was
funny ice cube was saying he felt like
The Gatekeepers are kind of like
stopping it I have seen it yet and I
feel like that too because he doing all
the mainstream media I think that it
would benefit from having some headline
players though that that uh
maybe could turn up from a hit from a
highlight standpoint that's what I think
I was going to say like when Iverson and
Jay will went into the year one yeah
that was ready to go berserk yeah and
then yeah because that made me want to
watch I was like wait white chocolate
and AI which is tough I'm in yeah me too
but the hard thing was like so Jay will
he was very played we got injured right
because he never came back after that
did he ever play at all maybe a game or
two we blew out his knee and then uh I
knew hey you know I played Iverson's
last game he ever played like I played
with him in China it was a three-game
tour it's on my my YouTube channel
really yeah it was fire but uh because
that was my guy what year was that
2012. wow so his kind of farewell tour
in China you were you were there yeah
2012. and well the last time he actually
took to the court and played a full game
but uh
so I knew but he barely wanted to do
that and then after that he never played
again so I knew in the big three was
somehow he's hooping I was like are you
sure people like to play like that
because at the end of the day like you
play on Iverson's level where like those
NBA All-Star even like me talking to kg
right
they ain't trying to the stakes are too
low it feels weird like going to play in
a game at a half full Arena or like if I
asked kg would you collab on my you he
gonna be like nah like why he's already
cemented that dude's Hall of Fame